back in 2012 I wrote my first cover
story for Forbes and we needed a trend a
famous person and something that had
never been done before at a certain
magnitude and found it in the form of
Justin Bieber investing in startups so
we put out the cover and we had a little
line on that said the most surprising
business story you'll read this year and
I think at the time it really was but
today things are a lot different some of
the biggest names in entertainment have
stakes in some of the most popular
startups that have now become multi
billion-dollar companies from uber to
Airbnb Spotify and so on so writing the
story on Justin Bieber really kind of
opened my eyes to what became a true
trend where athletes and entertainers
now have this path toward creating
generational wealth just by leveraging
the fame that they create during their
prime so how far back does this trend go
you could argue it dates all the way
back to Ty Cobb investing in coca-cola
or Babe Ruth getting into menswear but
it was never really a trend until about
a decade ago and what I think really
kicked off the modern-day version of
this was 50 cent back in the mid Ott's
he invested in vitamin water instead of
taking an endorsement check
he took equity and so 50 cent you know
really bet on himself he created his own
vitamin water flavor called formula 50
start in commercials and really kind of
merged his own identity with that of the
brand so when coca-cola came along and
bought the company for over four billion
dollars 50 cent walked away with about
100 million and that really opened a lot
of people's eyes to this phenomenon so
actually in 2016 when I wrote my next
cover story on this was about Ashton
Kutcher and he cited that moment with 50
cent as sort of an eye opener for him he
racked up steaks and Skype and
Foursquare early and then parlayed it
into partnership with Gayo Siri the
manager of Madonna and u2
and together they built a fund of their
own that invested in uber Airbnb Spotify
Pinterest you name it and they actually
managed to turn about 30 million dollars
in investment into quarter billion
dollars in just over five years
I think our earliest challenges were
just relative to credibility and
value-add like people would sort of
looking at well you guys are
entertainment guys like how's that value
add to its that company that we're
building and then we face the hurdle
again when we started making enterprise
bets and I feel like every vertical
there's a function of proving how all
the other things that we do actually
plug in to value on behalf of the
company once people saw that it wasn't
just about doing it you know sort of on
a one-off level like 50 cent had done
with vitaminwater but that you could
really create a diversified portfolio
with this stuff the trend really
exploded much like the way that athletes
such as Shaquille O'Neal went out west
to Los Angeles during their playing days
with the hopes of becoming movie stars
in the offseason or after they retired
now one of the big things is go to San
Francisco be neared the venture capital
scene rub elbows with funders and
founders etc and take somebody like
Kevin Durant who succeeded in doing that
in addition to winning championships he
also really built out his venture
capital career he started his own fund
much like Ashton Kutcher
it's called 35 ventures and invested in
companies from acorns to post maids to
coin base he's one of the more prolific
investors out there part of the reason
he ended up on the cover of Forbes
recently it was just a different crowd
when I went to San Francisco you know
being able to be around the tech crowd
being around a younger generation felt
like it was exactly where I needed to be
when it comes to being a young
entrepreneur you know so much
inspiration and so much innovation out
there as well so it was a it was perfect
it was a like a melting pot for people
especially young people
another big star who's done a fantastic
job of investing as Serena Williams her
firm Serena ventures has stakes and
dozens of startups from unicorns like
coinbase
to startups founded by women and
minorities like maven and she's really
at the forefront of trying to bring up
that next group of entrepreneurs to
create the next unicorns
you know perhaps in places where they
have not traditionally come from when I
first started I was like you know
everyone else I was like oh that's a
good company I want invest in that
that's a good company and I didn't
really have a theme or a motto but then
I learned that less than two
that of VC money was going to female
founders and even less to women and
people of color so I thought well that's
that's what I need to do I just start
supporting more companies like that and
I was like how do I raise awareness
about this and how it will also take a
lead on it so that was really important
to me to to do that and to continue to
do that and you know we're just starting
and we're just growing and girls so you
may be thinking why do we care that
these people who are already rich and
famous are becoming richer in fact
full-on wealthy and even more famous and
you know it's a fair question but when
you really dig in this is a group that
was treated as essentially wage laborers
that were paid in cash
perhaps handsomely but often died broke
now they're finding a way to have secure
futures and to flourish like the people
who were flourishing off of their
content in the past I think even more
importantly for the next generation
looking up they're able to see people
who look like them who came from places
like the places they came from in these
roles as investors as entrepreneurs and
it really opens up a whole array of
different careers that kids out there
can aspire to
[Music]